for every person there's a moment my
wife and I lost our home to a fire when
they discovered that the world when the
second plane hit it changed me and
everything they hold dear they placed in
my arms my first son tornado on the
ground phone lines were down
and that's why I'm a prepper that's why
I'm a prepper and that's why I am a
prepper
well some hope for the best go go go
these three that's worth 3 000 an ounce
are preparing hello Dad Dad where are
you at for the worst
they are
stay Preppers
[Music]
true story happened in Montana
a man his wife and his pet cat moved
into a Wilderness retreat
and they had all good intentions to live
up there you know year round and what
happened was when summer ended and
winter came
they weren't prepared for the 50 below
that they were about to encounter
in the springtime the authorities showed
up because nobody had heard from them
they found him sitting at a table in a
chair not a word coming out of his mouth
mumbling and out of his mind
with his wife and his dead cat lay
Frozen on the floor
and that's what happens when you're not
prepared and ready for what this place
can Dole out
that's why I'm a prepper
I've got enough food stockpile to last
me at least a year by many sources of
water will get me through any
catastrophe I have a network of stock
hideouts so I can bug out in moments
notice
I have an unlimited amount of wood I
won't be left in the cold I am preparing
for World War III
Jimmy believes that because of dwindling
resources and failing economies a major
world power will invade and occupy the
United States
is going to be your top dogs people like
China Russia and the US
hopefully they won't be stupid enough to
use nuclear weapons
land grabs are going on with Russia now
they're trying to reform the Soviet
Union the Chinese are sleeping like a
very dangerous Dragon they team up with
Russia we're going to be in a world of
trouble
in preparation for World War III 25
years ago Jimmy Falcon moved to a
secluded stretch of land a mile high
into the Rocky Mountains and seven miles
from the nearest town 25 years is a
pretty good time to acclimatize yourself
to extremes I'm probably a little bit
more capable of surviving pretty harsh
conditions whereas other people may not
a few decades ago I was under contract
where I had to work for the Department
of Defense my gut feeling said you know
you might better pack away a few things
and just kind of be ready for whatever
happens
if a war broke out the first year would
probably be awful we could get bombed
They're Gonna Knock Out all of our
Creature Comforts as far as our
electricity our Grid's going to get
knocked out people will panic
so everything in Jimmy's life is part of
his survival plan from the location of
his home to his two cats Montana holds
the record for the coldest temperature
ever recorded in the United States
outside of Alaska negative 70 degrees
not having heat is a matter of life or
death so Jimmy built his home to
withstand the extreme climate if you're
not acclimatized to the harsh conditions
when it gets 50 below and you don't have
any wood you are totally going to be at
Nature's mercy and nature is very
unforgiving to the people that are not
prepared
he's the biggest commodity when it gets
50 below it's got the most value of
anything up here
it's one week Jimmy burned through about
130 cubic feet of wood so survive each
winter he needs to collect up to 2500
cubic feet of wood wood is uh my main
source of heat if you don't have wood
you're done you know you're gonna freeze
Jimmy believes that if enemy forces
attack one of the first things people
will lose access to is water when our
country invades other countries the
first thing we do is knock out their
infrastructure what's to say that
another invading country would do the
same to us they're going to knock out
everything to make our lives miserable
although he lives near many Springs and
Creeks Jimmy feels it is necessary to
keep a backup supply of water I'll catch
it off the roof the gutter into a barrel
on a good day I can get a whole barrel
of water pumped up into the house I
protect my water like like no end mess
with my water you're in deep deep
trouble
the streams and creeks near Jimmy's home
don't just provide water in times of
geopolitical crisis at War investors
often turn to Precious Metals for
Financial Security everybody in the
entire planet knows what gold looks like
they know it's valuable and they will
want it it's that simple I think
post-apocalypse money cash paper and all
that stuff is probably going to be not
around so we're gonna go back to like
the way ancient times which is uh
precious metals okay I'm going to start
grabbing some moss and filling up this
pan and I'm dead I'm going to start
breaking it off to release the gold out
of the Moss and then I'll Pan the gold
[Applause]
the expression of that it didn't pan out
or it panned out all right comes from
gold mining so this didn't pan out right
here so I'm gonna move on down the creek
Montana is one of the top 10 producers
of gold and silver in the United States
in the aftermath of the world war he
fears if paper currency loses its value
Jimmy plans to use gold to barter for
goods
this is looking better already because
that's a piece of quartz the gold does
come out of quartz a lot of times oh
yeah looking good starting to see some
flakes
little piece right there wow if you
could pick it up with your thumb on your
index finger that's called a picker
that's what we want that's worth twice
spot weight right there so fifteen
hundred dollars an ounce just went to 3
000 an ounce I've been digging golf for
almost 25 years now this will be my job
in the woods one it's fan during World
War II gold coins were included in Air
Force survival kits so that downed
Pilots could use them to barter for food
though Jimmy feels he will be able to do
the same he's also stockpiling a year's
supply of food just in case I think
people are more than capable of turning
against each other in certain scenarios
you know seems like when the food Runs
Out people get a little weird especially
mamas
feeding children
they're The Dangerous Ones I've got
dehydrated food some canned food and
some noodles Jimmy keeps his food caches
stored in watertight bins underneath his
home I'm gonna stick this up onto the
house and hopefully it'll be safe for a
little while
Jimmy also plans to live off the elk and
deer that he can hunt on the surrounding
mountains but hunting big game can take
up to 12 days so he's training his two
cats Bubba and Kiki to hunt food for him
as well
cats are natural predators in the U.S
alone they hunt and kill billions of
birds and small mammals each year
after a long winter it looks like we're
going to go into training mode here
again and everybody's going to get a
tune-up my cats and myself included for
hunting and surviving and everything
else yeah these cats are my companions
they're they're good for me I talk to
them
they depend on me I take good care of
them so we're going to go out and do
some training today how's that huh
want to do some training
[Music]
Kitty bubble
bring me back some food
you're not gonna do this look at him run
he's running might have to starve these
cats
[Music]
baby
cat trading didn't go as good as I would
have liked it to have gone I will keep
training the cat I really truly believe
that they would bring me food if I was
laying there starving to death with a
broken leg I believe they would drop a
rabbit right on my chest
thank you
Jimmy's planning on surviving World War
III by living in isolation with Bubba
and Kiki and panning for gold to barter
but will his plans succeed in a
pre-apocalyptic world would you be
interested in trading for some gold
[Music]
in preparation for World War III Jimmy
Falcon is living in isolation with his
two cats in the unforgiving climates of
Montana's Rocky Mountains
he plans to hunt for meat on his land
but hunting Montana's elk deer and
muskrats can take a lot of time and
energy
so while he can he stocks up on meat and
other supplies at the nearest
supermarket one hour away I'm so used to
being out in the woods and up in the
country that when I go to town in the
big city it gets a little stressful kind
of sort of with all the people in the
traffic and everything
boy
I'll be in there
is there any way I could get you to cut
some meat for me please
thank you so much you're welcome
appreciate it you too
how are you I'm doing good would you be
interested in trading for some gold
I think gold is better than money
anyways that's interesting I don't think
anybody's ever tried that before oh yeah
look at that hey Jess up they're heavy
gold will be always good well yeah uh I
I don't know I might get in trouble
though today he wasn't successful at
bartering Jimmy still believes that
during and after World War III gold will
be the most valuable commodity I think
people can depend on stores and food
right now but not always that's for sure
Jimmy's preserving large quantities of
meat to supplement his Food Supplies by
using a method that has been around for
thousands of years smoking meat uh with
maple wood or any kind of hardwood gives
it a nice flavor and it preserves it for
a long time
smoking Mead helps kill bacteria and
conserves protein
jerky is commonly included in military
field rations because it's lightweight
has a long shelf life and requires no
further preparation
so in anticipation of World War III
Jimmy is using the SmokeHouse he built
on his property to prepare as much meat
as he can I just started a fire in this
Barrel stove down here and it's got a
flu that goes up in the floor of the
corner of the shed so right now that
Maple smoke is filling up in that little
walk-in Smokehouse and while the meat
smokes to conserve energy Jimmy takes
advantage of the valuable heat source
the heat from The Smokehouse
simultaneously warms an outdoor bath I'm
starting to smell good now this old
bubble bass got me smelling good now
get kind of stinky up here in the woods
just another day of paradise
[Music]
though he's built his home for survival
Jimmy's prepared to abandon it if the
war goes nuclear
one third of the nuclear missiles in the
U.S are located just four hours away in
Great Falls Montana at Maelstrom Air
Force Base which makes the area a Target
in the event of a nuclear attack Jimmy
plans to flee to a secret network of 24
caves which he maintains high in the
mountains
come on let's go
my strategy is actually to leave and go
where nobody wants to go I've been
training myself to do that for 20 years
I can walk out the back door and never
look back
my cats are gonna be right with me when
World War Three happens you know I'm not
going to leave them behind
come on baby let's go restock the cave
let's go put some new food in there
come on baby hurry come on let's go
before Bigfoot get you
[Music]
a cave is really good for nuclear
protection because uh nuclear has a hard
time penetrating through solid rock some
of it looks like it's getting close to
losing its shelf life so I'm either
going to eat it or toss it I don't like
to toss food
[Music]
I guess I'm ready for World War III I
guess
in a way you're never ready for
everything but my preps are very simple
and I think simple is good it's less
stuff to break so you know keep it
simple stupid everybody else might be
dead there might be six humans left on a
planet but they will procreate we'll
start this whole process over again
hopefully next time they'll get it right
to determine how long you could
initially survive a catastrophe
Practical Preppers has scored your preps
in five categories of 20 points each for
a total possible score of 100 food 16
out of 20 points water with its
abundance of Springs and streams you
chose your location wisely 19 out of 20
points shelter 18 out of 20 points
security 10 out of 20 points by living
this lifestyle for so many years you
know how to maximize your location 18 X
Factor points
overall you get an 81 out of 100 you
have 16 months initial survival time
it's our everyday is a new challenge and
I'll meet them challenges and persevere
foreign
has found that as resources dwindle it
could lead to increasing conflicts
around the world
but the United States has not been
invaded for nearly 200 years
[Music]
Cindy Stewart and her husband Randy are
passionate about making dead animals
look like they are very much alive
everybody's going to be trying to hunt
small games they're going to be hungry
but it's all part of their defensive
strategy to stop invader's dead in their
tracks
[Music]
September the 11th I was sitting at home
very pregnant watching the news when the
second plane hit and we all saw it it
became very evidently clear that it
wasn't an accident
started immediately trying to call Randy
on the cell phone I couldn't get him as
a matter of fact I couldn't get out on
the cell phone any at all for the rest
of that day
that was terrifying I knew Atlanta was a
Target I knew there are other planes in
the air
and I knew he was there
it changed me forever it changed my way
of thinking forever
it terrified me
down to my rear core
that's why I am a prepper
I have an arsenal of weapons to defend
my home and my family against any
foreign Invaders
I've built my home from the ground up to
protect against Invaders and evacuate if
necessary
I've got a whole community of people
that I prep with so I'll never have to
go It Alone
we're preparing for a foreign invasion
Cindy believes a foreign nuclear attack
on U.S military bases followed by a
ground attack on U.S soil is imminent
after the nuclear bombs to the bases
then comes the ground attack
the First Responders the people that
normally protect us they're going to
have to protect their own families then
people kind of go vigilante martial law
goes into effect I believe it's going to
be Insanity I believe it's going to be
chaos
I believe millions of people are going
to die
we're not going to have the government
to rely on we're going to have to
protect ourselves feed ourselves keep
our families alive keep them hidden
keep them safe
and 11. Cindy Stewart and her husband
Randy left a comfortable suburb of
Atlanta and moved 100 miles away to an
isolated community in Taylor County
Georgia
I was a dialysis nurse in Atlanta Randy
was working construction we had a nice
home it was paid for we still knew that
we had to go from the urban areas
we both quit our jobs and sold our home
and moved to a very rural area
that looks a little bit it's still
still too pink for me man Cindy and
Randy created a business they could run
without ever leaving their property
touch him up and he'll be ready to go
home full moon Taxidermy and goes hand
in hand with prepping
animals are a great resource for
everything their hives can be used for
clothing for shelter their bones for
weapons they're insides sewing material
when it's deer season we get freezers
full of free meat
the stewards have stored enough venison
to last six months but they're not
relying on only one source of food
having Adam learning hunting and fishing
and trapping
when something happens
if something happens he has got to know
how to take care of herself me and his
mom won't always be here
Randy has learned to cook meat in
underground pets a tactical technique
used by the U.S military to minimize the
smoke which could give away their
position
he smells like deer meat raccoon meat
smells like deer meat
but since the stewards live only 250
yards from the road and with the
abundance of local game they worry they
will become a Target
so defending their home and its
perimeter is a priority
[Music]
when you do that click click it's a
universal sound people know oh crap to
maximize their numerous weapons they
designed their home to look and function
like a military block house which is
often used to defend isolated areas
I live in a small tiny home for
defensive purposes I've sacrificed some
comfort and luxuries military block
houses are designed with heavy steel
doors as well as trap doors to store
supplies and ammunition but Cindy is
using these internal features for her
emergency plan the bathroom has a 400
pound door on it that can not easily be
kicked down torn through shot through
the bathroom is our safe room and it has
an escape hatch
we will not be trapped in here today
Cindy is putting her 11 year old son
Adam through a routine drill similar to
preparedness drills taught to Israeli
school children in the event of a rocket
or missile attack
you know what to grab okay if their home
is attacked by Invaders
Adam has been trained to grab supplies
and hide in a secret Alcove Cindy
designed for his Loft
and just hide yourself
good job
I'm a bad guy okay and so we're going to
practice on what to do next
I want the pillow I just want all this
stuff
oh oh there's a person there
bam I'm dead
don't hesitate Adam
I'm serious my mama is these juice with
me about once a week pretty much
it feels kind of scary and good at the
same time to go through stuff like that
you did awesome you did awesome it's a
lot for 11 year old to have to remember
I'm a mother just like anybody else out
there
you did good baby and my hope and my
prayer is that this never happens
listen to what I tell you I don't like
putting a pistol in his hand but we live
in a different time
things have changed
though Cindy has built her home to keep
her family safe protecting the perimeter
so they never reach it is her first
priority that's our perimeter and we
have to take action so she's creating a
series of camouflaged improvised
explosive devices to defend it
because of 9 11 Cindy's Cindy Stewart
relocated her family from Atlanta to a
rural County 100 miles away
she fears a foreign nuclear attack on
American military bases will be followed
by a land Invasion
with nuclear bombs there won't be
nothing left that's when us Americans
are going to be left around devices our
own defenses our own skills
Cindy feels that in order to keep her
family safe from Invaders it is critical
that they extend and protect their
defensive perimeter
a pack in a small game with some
explosives you can easily disguise it to
look like a regular animal sitting there
in the woods
the stewards are using their Taxidermy
skills to create camouflaged IEDs
improvised explosive devices to wound or
kill enemy soldiers that come on their
property
seven pounds that's gonna they're gonna
wipe out ten people
camouflage to fit into their environment
IEDs are often filled with nails broken
glass and ball bearings and can have a
kill radius of up to 250 feet
so I'm thinking right here because we've
got another entrance another Trail
people can follow
looking very realistic y'all very
realistic everybody's going to be trying
to hunt small games they're going to be
hungry it's going to make people curious
and they're going to come and look the
curiosity is going to kill the cat
oh it's covered
all right
talking pray works
he's our line of defense
with their animal IEDs strategically
placed along main entry points hey Randy
and Braun y'all want to come let's talk
about this last drill Cindy wants to be
sure they can reach their assigned
sniper positions quickly so that from
100 yards away they will be able to
detonate their targets undetected we're
on cover for the road is the one thing
that I'm concerned about so Brian you're
gonna grab the bag and your rifle and go
Randy you know just provide cover and
then I'm gonna go grab Adam and the
medical bag and I'm right behind y'all
sounds good to me sounds good to me it
sounds like a plan let's do it
foreign
I got you covered go go go go to reach
their perimeter safely the stewards use
a military technique called bounding
OverWatch get the car get the cards
which provides cover for units moving
rapidly forward and makes it difficult
for enemies to distinguish their targets
was leaving trying to get back here real
quick we forget those ammo cans or we
drop one we're in trouble there's a lot
that can go wrong and that's why it's
got to be precise and it's got to be
fast now we just need to test our
perimeter defenses
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
stay down
wow all right
if that works okay I've got to be honest
I think this the small one the squirrel
we're just kind of wasting our our ammo
with
I think that the Pheasant we might have
done a little bit of damage but that
raccoon
that's our last line of defense and
that's pretty impressive what did y'all
think
yeah this will definitely annihilate our
enemy I feel stronger I feel more able
to protect my family my home my life
than I did on 9 11. if Vigilantes were
trying to invade us aggressive action is
going to be returned with aggressive
action there's nothing that I'm not
willing to do
to save my family
[Music]
Practical Preppers has scored your preps
in five categories of 20 points each for
a total possible score of 100.
food
16 out of 20 points
water 13 out of 20 points
shelter 14 out of 20 points
curity 14 out of 20 points
as a taxidermist you have a wide range
of skills that will be useful in a
crisis situation 16 out of 20 points
overall you get a 73 out of 100 you have
13 months initial survival time 13
months well I'm pretty happy with the
score and I do also realize there's
things that we need to work on but
we're ready
a global arsenal of nearly 17 000
nuclear weapons makes the possibility of
an incident a tangible threat however
the United States and other countries
are moving towards a policy of nuclear
disarmament aimed at reducing the
likelihood of a nuclear war
foreign
army officer Rod Godfrey has built a
military-style command and control
center in his home okay to Romeo kilo
golf to protect himself from apocalyptic
superstorms but his greatest fears are
realized when a violent storm separates
him from the most important person in
his life Dad Dad are you there
[Music]
Dad
where are you during Hurricane Hugo I
was in Communications with another ham
radio operator on the island of Saint
Croix and he was relaying information to
us as to what was happening on the
island as the storm progressed and got
closer to him it got worse for him
at one part of the conversation he was
saying that it was the winds were
rocking his house and then all of a
sudden you heard his roof come off his
house you could hear it through the
microphone
you could hear the fear in this man's
voice you could hear in his voice that
he was scared to death for his life
I don't know if that gentleman lived or
died
that's why I'm a brother
I have a master control center where I
can monitor Global events in real time
constant source of natural gas so I will
always have power
I have a food pantry that will provide
me with food for up to six months I have
two proper Vehicles decked out with
state-of-the-art Communications
equipment I am prepping for natural
disasters based upon global climate
changes
scientific experts have determined that
due to man-made global warming Oceanic
temperatures are on the rise and many
believe that this is causing stronger
and more frequent storms rod thinks this
is just the beginning of what is yet to
come
it's the events that climate change
brings with it flooding high winds more
hurricanes more tornadoes and the
intensity of those storms and as we've
seen over the last five years it's
happening folks
American citizens are not ready for some
of the stuff that they might see in a
catastrophic event in their backyard
trying to find loved ones and family
members they can see their neighbors
laying dead in their backyard so that's
going to be a traumatic experience for
everybody
like most Preppers retired army officer
Rod Godfrey stocks food weapons
and maintains multiple sources of fresh
water but to prepare for the violent
storms and subsequent massive flooding
that he expects radical climate change
will bring what are you doing Bobby he
specifically purchased a property that
was 1200 feet above sea level
I moved here for two reasons number one
I'm high up on a hill
I am out of the way of any possible
threat of flooding number two My Radio
Systems will work fine with the
strongest signal that you can get
[Music]
most important things that I prepper was
going to need he's going to need the
ability to communicate a radio as long
as it has the capability to transmit and
receive is going to be something that's
going to protect you and save you
Rod has over 20 different radios and
communication support equipment worth
thousands of dollars and because he is
surrounded by the Appalachian Mountains
he has added two 50-foot antennas that
allow him to receive voice data and
satellite information from all around
the world every day when I get out of
bed I turn the radios on
and then I monitor all the emergency
Nets that I can I probably have at least
25 inputs where I I pull the information
from then I have to take that
information and I have to disseminate it
most people will just have one radio I
have multiple kinds of radios for
multiple missions high frequency HF VHF
and UHF CB radio have backup tube radios
here several modes of digital
capabilities I can even go digital with
Department of Defense this is what I
consider to be a Communications Hub
there's a lot of things that we can do
here that you're not going to be able to
do at your home Romeo
I'm retired military I was a
Communications specialist we actually
trained Army Navy Air Force Marines
Department of Defense civilians and even
FEMA
climate change will affect
Communications your house phone will
probably go down your cell phone will
probably go down during Katrina I
handled message traffic voice radio
communications and also relayed requests
for support
and his home after a military-style
command and control center so he and his
neighbors can utilize it as the local
hub for monitoring emergency channels
from here we got the farm go ahead and
to coordinate evacuation plans when
necessary now it's already in Calhoun
Calvin's right here Ron has assembled a
neighborhood call tree system a
pre-arranged organizational structure
with him at the center to quickly
contact his family and friends to spread
information as fast as possible
Romeo kilo golf calling CQ and listening
to maintain the operational security of
his C2 command and control rod ensures
that his communication system never
loses power
now to power your station in an
emergency especially when the
electricity goes out becomes a very very
important factor for a communicator most
Preppers they buy a gasoline generator
what I have here is a unique system
[Music]
I have my own natural gas well and this
is a gas well put in in 1900 it goes
down about 300 feet into a gas pocket if
needed I can switch over to the natural
gas generator it Powers 80 percent of my
own it is free gas
[Music]
disrupted during a storm
person for Rod to maintain direct
communication with is this 84 year old
father who lives down the hill at a
lower elevation very close with my
father hey are you home I see my father
every day he's always been my rock and
my pillar in order to include his father
in the emergency call tree system Rod is
giving him a Citizen band radio because
it requires minimal training Dad this is
off this is a CB radio it operates on
the upper side of the HF Spectrum we're
going to leave this on channel 14. that
is the emergency channel for Grantsville
if the landlines go out it's going to
give you Direct Communications into me
at the farm dad thinks I'm a little
crazy when it comes to prepping but he
supports everything that I do I'll see
you for breakfast in the morning yeah
that'll be good
Ron's greatest fear is realized when a
violent storm separates him from his
father
hello Dad Dad where are you
and puts his communication system to the
test upper Pine is starting to flood
here you're going to need to do
something pretty quick top is at 10-4
Rob Godfrey is a retired military
Communications specialist who is
preparing for violent storms and massive
flooding resulting from severe climate
change
you spend thousands of dollars to turn
his West Virginia home into a
military-style command and Control
Center National Weather Service Doppler
radar indicates a severe thunderstorm
capable of producing damaging winds
National Weather Service has notified us
of storms coming and the radar shows
that the storm is getting extremely
close Susan Susan where are you at are
you out there Susan radio is on as the
designated Hub or primary of his call
tree system Rod first communicates with
the secondary contacts who will continue
to advance the information hello Dawn
I'm here allowing him to continue to
gather information and coordinate
evacuation plans
I'm going to use you and Dawn you guys
are going to be inside the Communication
Center you're going to be running the
high frequency the VHF the UHF you'll be
providing interface between the 911
centers ambulance fire Crews anything
that's out there Dad Dad are you there
you're one Dad where are you
hello Dad
I don't know where he's at we're gonna
have to send somebody from the farm to
go pick him up in one of the vehicles
Craig Craig this is Rod uh you need to
come to this location Craig my next door
neighbor he is my closest Confidant when
it comes to prepping I haven't heard
from Dad at all you're going to have to
go pick him up take the Jeep re-radio
back if you have any problems but you
got to get him back over here ASAP all
right to extend their range emergency
service units have mobile command
centers that can respond to calls and
report back as the primary Rod should
never leave the command and control
center so he has equipped his two bug
out vehicles with multiple communication
devices this is a dual band radio you
have your UHF on this side and your VHF
on this side on the VHF side you'll be
communicating with me only on the UHF
side over here you'll be communicating
with local law enforcement in the 911
Center okay and you'll watch this this
tells me that that band is active now it
shows me that UHF is active oh I see
that
uh those guys are definitely getting
darker the wind has been picking up for
sure I'm seeing a few leaves and stuff
starting to blow by and uh the class
seamless like they are increasing in
speed
are the leaves blowing back and up or
back and down
uh Susan could you please check route
five for me please Route 5 West see
knowing the the way the wind is acting
and the way the leaves are blowing that
tells you a lot about the storm you can
tell by the leaves if they do this that
means one thing if they do this that
means one thing and if the leaves are
constantly shaking and doing this that
means get out of the way because the
storm is getting extremely close
the purpose of command and control is to
rapidly receive and distribute Act ual
Communications including alternate
routes
part of their training radio operators
are taught to stay calm while giving
clear and concise instructions under
stressful circumstances okay now I
noticed that we've got a little bit of
problems with some roads so we're going
to have to route you a little bit
differently yeah copy that 10-4 uh
you're gonna have to go up through Upper
Pine in order to get out you can't get
out at the bottom of the hill
so it does
all right I just want to let you know
that I've made it over your dad's uh
we're gonna get we're getting stuff
together right now oh man
okay make sure that dad does not forget
his uh diabetic supplies and all of his
medicine that's in the cabinet because
he also has high blood pressure too so
yeah
and uh he's ready to go sounds good
we'll be waiting Roger out
the only Surefire bit that you're going
to have and it hit the fan scenario is
Radio communication that's your only
guarantee because everything else is too
dependent on something else
all you know is that you better have a
plan in place because to not plan is to
fail and to fail is to die in this
situation
Practical Preppers has scored your preps
in five categories of 20 points each
food 16 out of 20 points
water 13 out of 20 points
shelter 16 out of 20 points
security 18 out of 20 points your
experience in operating your radio
communication system will allow you to
leave many people out of danger 20 X
Factor points
overall you get an 83 out of 100 you
have 18 months initial survival time
that's not bad I think it's a very fair
and honest evaluation
scientists across the United States
agree that climate change is occurring
and that humans are contributing to it
and recommend immediate action however
its short-term impact on weather
patterns is uncertain
[Music]
foreign